en tout cas je vais essayer de ne pas
vous livrer des opinions personnelles
mais de me rendre compte d'un consensus
entre toutes les institutions enfin
toutes les personnes qui représentent
des institutions que j'ai que je vous ai
détaillé alors le premier élément
sur lequel je vous propose de nous
attarder un instant c'est le rapport des
dépenses de retraite à la richesse
nationale une retraite par répartition
ça veut dire qu'on prélève les
cotisations ou des impôts sur les actifs
pour financer les retraites et donc
c'est une manière synthétique de
d'apprécier le
l'effort qu'il faut faire pour les
retraités que de considérer le la part
des dépenses de retraite dans le PIB en
gros ça dit c'est qu'il faudrait
prélever sur les actifs je ne vais pas
commenter le passé vous voyez que ça a
fortement augmenté dans les années 2000
le baby-boom la crise économique des
années 2010 vous avez le soubresaut lié
au covid et puis
2021 le dernier chiffre connu c'est les
dépenses de retraite c'est très virgule
8% du PIB vous voyez ensuite qu'il y a
une seule ligne jusqu'en 2030 parce que
là nous sommes calés sur les prévisions
économiques du gouvernement donc il n'y
a pas de il n'y a pas d'hypothèse à
partir de 2030 vous voyez que il y a 4
courbes parce que nous sommes amenés par
consensus au sein du corps à faire des
hypothèses sur la croissance de la
productivité horaire du travail qui
détermine le niveau des salaires et qui
détermine aussi le niveau du niveau du
PIB et vous voyez que selon les
hypothèses que l'on prend on a des
résultats différents alors le spectre
d'hypothèse sur lequel nous travaillons
dans le rapport c'est entre
0,7% de croissance annuelle de la
productivité du travail en gros ce qu'on
a connu entre
2009 et 2019
c'est la plus défavorable et la plus
favorable
1,6%, c'est en gros ce qu'on a connu
entre
1982 et 2022 d'accord sur 40 ans
vous voyez que les résultats sont très
différenciés globalement pour résumer
tout ça même s'il y a quelques vagues en
gros les dépenses de retraite sont
relativement stables vous voyez qu'il y
a quelques vagues et même à long terme
dans trois d'hypothèses sur quatre elle
diminue quelque peu puisque dans
l'hypothèse la plus favorable on finit à
11h 12 % dans l'hypothèse orange je
précise que l'hypothèse orange 1% c'est
celle qui sert de référence pour la
réforme des retraites c'est c'est le cas
adopter le gouvernement parce que si
nous au corps nous pouvons gérer un
spectre d'hypothèse dans un rapport de
constat pour présenter une réforme il
faut avoir une seule référence et donc
c'est l'hypothèse orange qui a été
retenue par le gouvernement pas la plus
pas la plus défavorable mais celle qui
suit immédiatement il n'y a que dans
l'hypothèse grenat 07% de croissance de
la productivité que les dépenses de
retraite augmentent quelques peu à
l'horizon 2050 puisqu'il passe de 13,8 à
14 14 4 je précise que 0 1 point de
Bible en 2021 le PIB c'était 2500
milliards et que donc 01 point de PIB
c'est 2,5 milliards je vais vous parler
en permanence en point de PIB donc pour
avoir une idée de ce que ça valait en
2021 retenez 01
= 2,5 1% égale
25 parfait merci monsieur le président
donc
[Musique]
c'est pour ça que vous voyez que ça
diminue plus dans l'hypothèse verte que
dans l'hypothèse grenat alors pourquoi
ça diminue c'est parce que au régime
général les pensions sont indexées sur
les prix et donc quand les salaires
augmentent rapidement et bien il y a un
décrochage des pensions par rapport au
salaire et donc par rapport au PIB c'est
parce que Arco agir il y a eu des
mesures qui ont visé à faire baisser
durablement le rendement technique
d’arco Agirc et enfin la fonction
publique les périodes de gel du point
qui sont passés et qui sont projetés
dans nos dans nos hypothèses boutissent
aussi à peser sur le niveau des pensions
par rapport par rapport au salaire donc
si j'ai pu vous dire que les dépenses de
retraite ne dérapaient pas c'est parce
que ces deux forces vont en sens
contraire et comme dans un problème de
physique alimentaire en gros et c'est un
hasard c'est pas quelqu'un qui qui l'a
voulu qu'il aurait organisé et bien elle
se contrebalance alors bien évidemment
si les pensions
des relatives des retraités baisse par
rapport aux rémunérations c'est c'est un
choix une question ça veut dire que
aujourd'hui le niveau de vie des
retraités et légèrement supérieur à
celui de l'ensemble de la population
même si on ne prend pas les loyers
imputés et les retraités sont souvent
souvent propriétaires que les autres
mais même sans loyer imputés c'est un
peu supérieur le niveau de vie et
du fait de la baisse relative des
pensions ce niveau de vie qui est
aujourd'hui un peu supérieur l'ensemble
de la population
diminuerait pour se situer autour de 80%
alors qu'aujourd'hui il est à plus de
100% d'accord donc bien évidemment
si les dépenses de retraite ne dérapent
dans un contexte de vieillissement ça a
un revers qui est la baisse relative du
niveau des pensions et donc la baisse du
niveau de vie relatif des retraités par
rapport à l'ensemble de la population
[Musique]